throughout his campaign joe biden
promised america he wouldn't let china
eat our lunch
but don't take my word for it china is
going to
eat our lunch come on man they're not
bad folks folks but guess what
they're not a cut they're not
competition for us
but then after just one phone call
with china's president biden turned
around and said
this i was on the phone
for two straight hours with xi jinping
they'll get moving they're going to need
our lunch
next week the baid administration will
hold its first high-level meeting with
chinese communist party leadership
the only question what's going to be on
the menu
them or us joining me now former dni
director former united states attorney
former congressman from the great state
of texas
johnny radcliffe john how are you trey
good to be with you
all right i want you to imagine you're
at this meeting you're sitting at the
table
what is john ratcliffe going to ask the
chinese
well i can tell you the early readout
from the biden uh white house is that
they're going to talk to the chinese
about
trade and intellectual property cyber
security
and a few other issues the one thing
that i haven't seen them mention
is the one that i would start with which
is china's role
uh in kovid 19. as you know trey
yesterday was the one year anniversary
of
uh covid19 being declared a pandemic a
pandemic that's claimed the lives of
a half a million americans and to put
that in perspective that's more
americans lost to covid19 that were lost
in world war one
and world war ii combined and so
you know as the person who for the past
year has seen all of our intelligence
related to china's role
in connection with this virus we
typically don't use legal terms in the
intelligence community but as a
prosecutor trade you'll appreciate that
i think the best way to describe it is
to say
that china's actions were a direct and
proximate cause of the death of all
one half million americans as a result
of covid19
so if i were sitting down with china
that's where i would start
and i wouldn't move on until i got a
commitment from them to get the
cooperation that we need
to move forward and get the answers to
make sure that we never have a pandemic
like this again
you know john you have been so
passionate even off-camera when we talk
i mean your passion is i mean this could
happen again it's great we have a
vaccine
it's great there's hope on the horizon
but this could happen again
and there's still on unanswered
questions about the origins aren't there
there are and that's why it's important
you know operation warp speed is a huge
success and those vaccines will end this
pandemic but they won't
stop the next pandemic the only way we
stop this and again this is not about
just about assigning blame to china and
getting answers with respect to that
it's about preventing the next one
because
if we don't get clarity with regard to
tracing this to a specific source
then we can't prevent the next pandemic
from happening and that's where
we have so much that is still unanswered
we put out a lot of information
and and folks need to know that on
january 15th
when mike pompeo put out a a a statement
from the state department that talked
about the intelligence at the world
at the wuhan institute of virology and
all of the information that we had about
the ccp's involvement in ordering
experimentation on coronaviruses
that was information that i approved on
behalf of the intelligence community and
the reason that we did that trey was
that
mike and i knew that we were walking out
of an administration and we didn't know
whether this administration
would keep their foot on the gas and get
the answers that we need for the
american people
and our concern based on just that clip
that you played shows that
the rhetoric on china has been pretty
good but the actions haven't backed it
up and
our concern is that we may not get those
answers
if if they don't keep their foot on the
gas
you know john i think most americans
agree with you i mean we can talk about
trade we can talk about the other stuff
the south china sea but first and
foremost we want to know how this
happened and what steps you're taking to
make sure it doesn't happen
again i think that you have channeled
the passions of the american people
before i let you go let me ask you about
the middle east because i know you're
passionate about that
what changes do you see in the biden
approach to the trump approach
well the biden administration seems so
intent on proving president trump wrong
that they're going to
prove him right at the sake of national
security and literally snatch
defeat from the jaws of victory we're
enjoying relative peace in the middle
east because
iran is poorer weaker and less
influential than they've been in decades
and nobody
can argue otherwise with a straight face
and that's because we've pulled out of
the jcpoa
and implemented sanctions that have
really put
um the iranian regime on on the verge of
real trouble
and have prevented them from engaging in
the kind of mayhem across the middle
east
that has allowed these peace agreements
these peace accords to move forward
and the trump administration wants to go
the opposite direction
even though what you hear is that
our israel does not want jcpoa
our arab allies do not want the jcpoa
the only ones that seem to be moving
forward are russia and china so
why the biden administration would be
listening to them and trying to move
forward on this
it really is baffling but it's
jeopardizing national security i hope
that they will back off
well johnny thank you for coming on
tonight thank you for your service to
our country uh
our best of michelle and your two
daughters we'll see you soon
thanks trey coming up